One of the things I'm always trying to
fight is this idea that technology
is a cold weird thing. Or that mass
produce items whether it's a blender a
car or computer are simply dead things
within themselves. Like the humans once
they get their hands on the things love
the things. And their love of the things
make these things come alive! So there is
a benefit in collecting things, right?
Because there's a part of you that comes
in there. It becomes part of the story of
your life. The story you tell. It becomes
the talisman. And here's the thing...
when I was in my teens, I started calling computer bulletin board systems
and i love them. I racked up incredible amounts of bills.
This is another yearbook photo where i am posing
with my BBS. So, yeah, that's right.
And you're like, wow, Jason you also
have some weird stuff in there.
Cryptographic message... how to make chicken littles
from a KFC that one of my friends worked at.
Lysol. There's a whole thing with...
there's a whole thing with shop vacs.
And that's why that's there. The DustBuster.
I made sure that I had a DustBuster
in every photo of me in the yearbook.
I don't know sometimes I think, like,
they're just this blowing door and I come out...
I go 'WHAT are you thinking?!'
And then leave again. No advice, no nothing, just:
Stop it!
But, you know, anyway DustBusters.
Love them. But the thing was was
when I call bulletin board systems and I'm
assuming people know. A bulletin board
system is a bulletin board system is
basically a computer with a modem with
a lonely person at it who then keeps code up
so that when other lonely people call
them
they leave messages about how angry they are
at the world because they're lonely and then
other people disagree with them...
And nobody gives anybody hugs, and, um --
anyway so the point is that these things were kind of
a self-made world, right? You would pay enormous
amounts of money at the time to put
a computer on a phone line.
I mean this is all very expensive.
And then other people would call and
use your computer and post to it,
but the thing was that they were transient
they were unbelievably transient.
They would go away after like 5 or 6 months.
And some of them would stay around for
a year or two or disappear.
Jason, who had previously learned that the world
was messed up, would back up everything he found.
So if I found anything on a website that I liked. That
told me about the place or had quote unquote 'text files'
where you could go and find out
how to make a bomb, how to fix the modem,
how to get angry at the world, 10 terrible lightbulb jokes,
I just grabbed them all.
I just grabbed them all and put them all on floppy disks.
Until I have a stack of floppy disks.
And when bulletin board systems stopped
being important in my life--okay, that's not right.
When bulletin board systems stopped
being a thing I did daily...
I ended up going to you know college and
I found a way to get on through the MIT system
into the Internet at like 18 or 19,
and, you know, once you're doing the heroin
it's hard to go back to marijuana
And so I ended up storing away those floppies.
And in 01998 I thought,
"Man, I sure had fun on those BBSes!"
And now I'm 28. And the web is up.
And the web has everything now. It's got Alta Vista.
It's pretty. It's got lots of... the text will center now.
You can effect the font. The sky's the limit!
So let me go look up about my favorite
Bulletin Board System: Sherwood Forest 9143591517
And let's go find out what's going on with them.
No information. That's weird.
How about bulletin board systems of New York?
Nothing. Ooh. How about bulletin board systems?
Not much. All right. What happened here?
Now, friggin 20 years of research has
revealed to me what happened
I'll tell you in a moment, it's not that interesting.
But basically bulletin board systems
were persona non grata on the Internet.
And so I was like, but I have all these old text files!
Well, why don't I put them all up?
So I ended up grabbing textfiles.com
and I put up 50,000 text files
that i had collected over those years.
And all these people came out of the woodwork to go
first: oh my god all these old things!
And, more importantly: I have stuff and I don't want it.
You obviously do. Would you like the stuff now?
And I'm like: Yes! Yes, please send me the stuff!
Send me cd-roms. Send me piles of floppies.
Send me whatever you want to.
And I'll pull them up on textfiles.com. and textfiles.com grew
and grew and grew and I became known,
whether I wanted to (or not) as a historian.
As an archivist; as a librarian.
I did not go to school for these things.
I went to school with a film degree, okay?
I graduated from high school, this is very true,
this is not me being funny.
I graduated from high school with
a 1.7 grade point average
That is very hard to do without shooting the place up
But I did it. I did it!